il ya 50 ans la chirurgie était
pratiquement le seul moyen de lutte
contre le cancer
aujourd'hui la chimiothérapie la
radiothérapie et d'autres traitements
médicaux interviennent dans cette lutte
dans certains cas de leucémie on a
recours à des greffes de moelle osseuse
cette méthode consiste à injecter au
malade de la moelle soit après l'avoir
prélevé sur le malade lui-même soit de
la moelle provenant d'un donneur
dans ce dernier cas la difficulté est de
trouver un donneur dont les tissus sont
compatibles avec le receveur et bien il
y a quelque chose de nouveau depuis
depuis deux ans est une initiative de la
ligue nationale qui est l'institution de
ce qu'on appelle et soes cancer cet
organisme et y répond par téléphone aux
702 15 15 à paris tous les jours de la
semaine du lundi au vendredi non pas
pour donner des conseils médicaux au mal
à ce n'est pas son rôle du tout mais
vous le rapportez l'appui psychologique
et moral depuis 79 le centre spécialisé
de l'hôpital minjoz à traiter 170
malades après avoir été irradiés la
moelle et conservé par congélation à
moins de 196 degrés les symptômes de la
maladie hémorragie diffuse anémie et
grande fatigue accompagnée de pierre
alors là vous venez de subir une greffe
de moelle allogénique ça veut dire que
c'est une de vos soeurs qui vous a donné
de sa moelle
comment vous sentez vous
on vous a laissé combien de temps encore
les malades sont isolés dans des bulles
afin d'éliminer tout risque d'infection
fabriqué en france ces bus dans été
offert par le comité de la ligue contre
le cancer
en dehors des dons versés par ces dix
sept mille adhérents
on s'est demandé si la ligue recevait
des subventions absolument aucune et mon
seul ressources sont les cotisations ni
dons et les sens que nous retrouvons au
cours de la semaine
du cancer sur un point ce n'est que je
veux insister ce qui distingue lanig
plus notre association c'est que les
fonds qui sont recueillies sont utilisés
à 90% dans le département les 10%
restants sont versés à la ligue
nationale qui a évidemment ses propres
besoins
dans ce centre simule sont à la
disposition des malades
il pourrait y en avoir davantage si ce
centre un des premiers de france
disposer de plus d'argent